bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du parlement ndour compagne de
michaël szames est bon je omis quel jour
on est ensemble pour 45 minutes pour un
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec cette semaine bien
sûr l'audition de jérôme cahuzac devant
la commission d' enquête parlementaire
deux heures d'audition avec des
questions souvent beaucoup plus longue
que les réponses
l'ancien ministre du budget qui s'est
souvent retranchés derrière l' enquête
judiciaire pour ne pas répondre aux
questions très précises
un peu plus tôt c'est un autre ancien
ministre dominique strauss-kahn qui
était auditionné par les sénateurs de
l'ancien directeur du fmi était là pour
donner en quelque sorte une leçon
d'économie devant la commission d'
enquête sur l'évasion fiscale entreprise
de réhabilitation ou pas cette audition
n'a pas été du goût de tous les
sénateurs
enfin nous reviendrons sur cette
opération transparence voulue par
françois hollande
les députés ont voté cette semaine les
textes sur la transparence de l'aide
publique et sur la fraude fiscale
y at il de réelles avancées avec ses
textes on tentera d'y répondre dans
cette émission est avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité nicolas
dupont aignan bonjour bonjour député
maire de yerres dans l'essonne vous êtes
aussi le président de debout la
république vous avez été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et j'ai une
question toute simple pour commencer
c'est vrai qu'on ne vous a pas beaucoup
vu entendu depuis l'année dernière
depuis cette élection présidentielle
c'est quoi c'est un voeu ou est ce que
c'est parce que c'est un passage à vide
forcément après une élection
présidentielle j'ai pas eu le sentiment
d'avoir un passage à vide en tout cas
j'ai travaillé c'est peut-être que les
journalistes étaient moins intéressés
par mon travail plus secret mais
j'ai travaillé beaucoup notamment sur
les paradis fiscaux tommy son enquête
développer le mouvement n'a eu beaucoup
d'adhérents depuis depuis un an donc
installé debout la république sur le
territoire voilà un travail de fond
plutôt que la médisance chaîne qui se
voit moins mais pour autant il ya du
travail
est ce que vous serez candidat à la
mairie
cette fois je présidentielle prochaine
des municipales à yerres dans l'essonne
trilogie verrions bien sûr c'est vous
savez j'ai été élu en 95
dans une ville en faillite j'ai
l'honneur d'être le maire le mieux élu
de france j'ai eu 80 % des voix en 2008
dans une ville de 30 mille habitants je
crois que c'est un bel honneur et je
sais est un des plus beaux mandat le que
vous faites des choses puisque vous
faites du non-cumul alors on verra
vous savez entre mère et sa fille têtue
vrai dire on est dans un pays
extraordinaire où en fait on va avoir le
droit d'être avocat d'affaires et député
mais on n'aura pas le droit d'être mère
de sa petite ville qu'on aime le seul
territoire
mais attendez ce qu'elle est votée on
verra c'est parce je veux dire moi je
suis convaincu que les français ont
besoin des lieux avec des racines ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut généraliser le
cumul
je suis pour qu'on interdise un cumul le
cumul des rémunérations
définitivement et puis après qu on lit
ce qu'on laisse les électeurs garder des
élus de terrain viendra soit transparent
ça va commencer lundi avec villeneuve
sur lot le front républicain en question
en ce lundi le ps mais aussi l'ump ont
la gueule de bois jean louis costes
candidat ump l'a certes heures remporté
remporté la législative partielle de
villeneuve sur lot mais avec moins de
54% des voix face à son rival du front
national et malgré l'appel du ps a voté
pour lui alors évidemment on s'interroge
sur l'efficacité de ce front républicain
thibout le floch c'est ça
merci marine au bout de la ligne
marine le pen elle félicite son candidat
etienne bousquet cassagne émules ce
novice en politique a obtenu 46 24 % des
suffrages
hier dans la troisième circonscription
de lot-et-garonne la victoire s'est
jouée avec 2500 voix d'écart ce qui
permet au candidat du fn de se montrer
triomphant malgré la défaite
c'est une défaite qu un petit goût de
victoire tout de même parce que réalisé
un tel score dans une terre socialiste
radical socialiste is hier
lot-et-garonne
c'est ça peut être inimaginable mais
hier soir à l'annoncé des résultats
certains militants du fn n'était pas
satisfait de cette deuxième place
selon eux le candidat ump jean louis
costes a été sauvé par les votes des
socialistes et ils sont venus le lui
dire
les idées du front national
incontestablement pèse aujourd'hui voilà
puisque ça fait deux élections
partielles l'oise et le lot-et-garonne
dans laquelle on avait des
configurations petit peu différent même
si aujourd'hui le résultat ici est
meilleur voilà effectivement il ya quand
même un électorat qui a voté front
national sur un deuxième tour en effet
le front national a gagné sept mille
voix de plus par rapport au premier tour
mais ce matin le chef de file des
députés socialistes l'affirment
aucun de ces électeurs n'a voté front
national n'a pas été élu et heureusement
et aucun électeur de gauche n'a voté
pour le front national et doutes sur mon
tour vous suit je regarderai la logique
même son de cloche chez françois
hollande en déplacement au qatar
selon lui ce sont les voix des
socialistes qui ont permis l'élection du
candidat de l'ump pour le chef de l'état
cette huitième défaite consécutive pour
des législatives partielles va forcément
amener le ps à réfléchir à sa stratégie
pour gagner les municipales de 2014
le front national a perdu mais de peu
peut-on dire c'est le front national a
raison de parler de défaite au goût de
victoire
ce que je crois c'est que c'est la fin
enfin de l'alternance automatique entre
le parti socialiste et l'ump
je crois qu'on est à la fin d'un système
et je m'en réjouis parce que ce sont
deux parties qui gouverne la france mal
depuis 20 ans ce sont deux parties qui
ont échoué et enfin les français s'en
rendent compte et tout ce qui permettra
d'accélérer la fin de ce système qui
ruine la france sera positif donc est ce
que le format suivant la troisième force
du pays aujourd'hui
en revanche la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est de savoir quelles
alternatives
on va bâtir donc et c'est le sens de mon
combat politique
il ya l'alternative de madame le pen
mais moi je veux bâtir une autre
alternative et je suis absolument
convaincu que si c'est une alternative
patriotique gaulliste républicaine on
accélérera encore plus la fin de ceux-ci
station prend l'exemple
neuf sur lot et des doutes législatives
partielles avec le front national arrive
aujourd'hui très haut est ce que c'est
la troisième force du pays
ou pas je ne crois pas totalement je
crois que les français ont compris
l'échec absolu du ps et l'ump et donc
comme aujourd'hui c'est le front
national qui est le parti le plus connu
comme alternative ils votent pour le
front national
mais je pense que tout l'enjeu des
prochaines années justement c'est de
bâtir l'offre politique de
reconstruction du pays
c'est à dire que moi ce qui m'intéresse
maintenant et c'est le sens de mon
combat c'est de dire aux français voilà
on va se débarrasser du système ce sont
les morts ce système il mort ça c'est
mais tout ça c'est fini il faut voir où
on est la seule question qui va se poser
c'est est-ce que l'alternative ce sera
marine le pen et le front national
ou est ce que ce sera dupont aignan et
d'autres qui le faisaient vous avez dit
qu éventuellement florian philippot dans
un gouvernement ce sera pas de nouvelles
choses vice-président du front national
maintiens ma théorie je n'ai jamais
changé nationale tout ça c'est d'un
ridicule
g je n'ai jamais changé d'avis je crois
que quand la maison brûle on regarde pas
la couleur des pompiers à la condition
que le chef des pompiers est une ligne
irréprochable
est ce que j'ai dis et je maintiens
c'est que je considère qu'il faut sauver
la france
et moi je souhaite le faire avec des
gens de gauche des gens de droite avec
tous les patriotes formations du front
national sur ma ligne
s'ils sont sur ma ligne gaulliste
républicaine patriotique c'est la même
chose attendez je tapais bien juste
c'est pas du tout la même chose que
d'être mois sur la ligne de marine le
pen il ya plusieurs forces politiques
d'alternative en france quel front de
gauche on peut ne pas aimer mélenchon
c'est une force alternative
je suis pas d'accord avec lui c'est une
force alternative il ya marine le pen
c'est une force alternative elle existe
il faut arrêter là dédiaboliser de la
diaboliser et puis il y a je pense la
seule force alternative qui à terme
pourra reconstruire le pays parce qu'il
s'agit pas d'avoir deux colère oui oui
non la question en vue des municipales
accord ou pas mais les forces armées
votre parti mais il n'y a pas une
question d'accord pas d'accord les
municipales c'est un scrutin local où ça
les prochaines élections alors les
européennes par exemple aux européennes
je présenterai une liste vous n'avez pas
compris ce que je vous ai je faisais dit
totalement compris qu'il faut bâtir une
alternative crédible de reconstruction
politique
il y a deux colère qui s'exprime en
france celle de mélenchon
celle de marine le pen elle se rapproche
d'ailleurs remarquer une chose que
marine le pen est plus en plus à gauche
e moi je suis pas d'accord avec
certaines des solutions de marine le pen
je pense qu'elles ne sont pas
opérationnels pour reconstruire le pays
et donc il est normal que je dise aux
français on va se débarrasser du ps et
l'ump qui échoue mais on n'est pas
obligé
on n'est pas obligé de voter front
national il ya autre chose qui existe y
aura le front national y aura debout la
république il y aura le front de gauche
et les françaises pourront enfin choisir
une nouvelle alternative y seront pas
condamnés dans le terrible choix ou le
système qui échoue ou le front national
nicolas dupont aignan a passé à notre
sujet on en a parlé ici la semaine
dernière vous rappelez peut-être des
propos de josé manuel barroso concernant
cette france réactionnaire et bien le
débat s'est encore enflammé cette
semaine le président de la commission
européenne a répondu arnaud montebourg
qui a dit que le président de la
commission européenne était le carburant
du front national on voit tout ça avec 4
gilbert
le bras de fer s'est durci au beau
milieu du g8 mardi dernier en marge du
sommet josé manuel barroso a plus
implicitement la france d'avoir une
attitude réactionnaire allusion à paris
qui a menacé de sortir son veto pour
exclure l'audiovisuel des négociations
commerciales en cours avec washington
françois hollande fait mine d'ignorer la
petite phrase mais dimanche la tension
monte d'un cran depuis paris arnaud
montebourg tire à boulet rouge contre le
président de la commission européenne
tous ceux qui chantent i mondialisation
ceux des réactionnaires part aux jo et
le carburant du front national voilà la
vérité nouvelle charge 24 heures plus
tard sur la même antenne la ministre du
logement renchéri
aujourd'hui on peut avoir le sentiment
que l'europe c'est une forme de
gendarmes qui regardent de haut les pays
et qui ne bâtit pas l'avenir la
polémique oppose bruxelles à une partie
de la gauche mais pas seulement à droite
l'ancien premier ministre alain juppé
fustige l'attitude totalement archaïque
du président de la coalition et sa
vision du monde des années 58
l'intéressé exerce son droit de réponse
quelques heures plus tard droit sur sa
ligne le chef de l'exécutif européen
fait la leçon à ses adversaires
il serait bon que certains responsables
politiques comprennent que ce n'est pas
en attaquant l'europe et en essayant de
faire de la commission le bouc émissaire
de ses propres difficultés qu'ils allons
arriver très loin certains finalement
souverainistes de gauche font exactement
le même discours
l'extrême droite depuis deux mois le ton
monte entre paris et bruxelles cette
fois à trois jours du conseil européen
la tension est à son comble barroso
carburant du front national c'est
quelque chose que j'aurais pu reprendre
dans votre propre voix ou pas écoutez il
ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie des socialistes
parce qu'en fait qui a donné le pouvoir
à barroso qui est allé se prosterner
devant la commission de bruxelles qui a
voté à l'assemblée nationale le traité
budgétaire qui soumet le parlement
français à des technocrates non élus qui
sont des agents américains
c'est monsieur hollande monsieur
montebourg
madame duflot monsieur juppé c'est à
dire que moi je conteste bien sûr
l'arrogance et surtout l'inefficacité du
pauvre barroso parce que ils mettent
l'europe à feu et à sang
mais ça c'est un dérivatif pour eux en
vérité nous avons une classe politique
soumise à bruxelles qui mène une
politique suicidaire pour la france
mais comme ils s'aperçoivent quand même
qu'à une colère populaire
ils se disent on va critiquer barroso en
faire une cible
et puis les français verront du feu mais
les français ils sont intelligents
les français veulent de la cohérence
donc soit monsieur hollande va comme il
fait depuis un an
obéir à bruxelles et critique pas
barroso soit eux y critique barroso mais
il n'applique pas des directives
qui plonge le pays dans la récession le
chômage de masse et les troubles sociaux
et politiques
et moi je propose une autre politique
j'ai toujours été cohérent
j'ai refusé de signer des traités
dangereux on paye aujourd'hui le danger
de ces traités ou les pêcheurs en
chômage en insécurité en immigration et
il faut changer de politique c'est tout
voilà allez on va passer au mardi il n'y
a pas que l'europe qui nous réclame plus
de rigueur et bien aussi les députés ump
en ce mardi le président de la
commission des finances gilles carez
l'ump gilles carez convoque la presse
pour donner le résultat de ses propres
calculs ce n'est pas 60 mais 80
milliards d'euros qui manqueront dans
les caisses de l'état d'ici la fin de
l'année
entouré d'un aéropage de membres ump de
la commission des finances
il demande donc au gouvernement de
revoir sa copie elisa berthelot mais il
réclame de la transparence et une
opération vérité sur les comptes publics
les commissaires aux finances de
l'opposition pointe des problèmes dans
l'exécution du budget 2013
augmentation des dépenses moins de
rentrées de tva et d'impôt sur le revenu
que prévu et pour le président de la
commission des finances une conséquence
clair on a voté en décembre entre la loi
de finances pour l'état et la loi de
financement pour la sécurité sociale
un déficit de trois points de pipe 60
milliards je prévois au jour
d'aujourd'hui un déficit d'au moins 4
points de pib c'est à dire 80 milliards
au total selon les calculs des députés
ump le déficit de l'état devrait dérapé
de 20 milliards d'euros en 2013 dont 10
milliards dus au manque de recettes
fiscales dans le cadre de leur opération
vérité
ils réclament une loi de finances
rectificative au gouvernement une option
rejetée par la majorité qui renvoie
gilles carez à son bilan
la stabilité fiscale elle est assurée
pendant l'année 2013 comme elle ne l'a
jamais été
nos prédécesseurs 15 loi de finances
rectificative en cinq ans nous avons
fait une loi de finances rectificative à
notre arrivée c'était bien normal
d'ailleurs pour nettoyer à l'eau
parce budgétaire de nos prédécesseurs
mais nous ne ferons pas cet été ni cet
automne pour christian eckert il est
encore trop tôt pour faire un bilan du
budget 2013 pour l'heure la majorité
maintient ses prévisions de croissance
et de réduction des déficits et paris
sur un rebond de l'économie d'ici la fin
de l'année mais pas que bruxelles 1 qui
réclament plus de rigueur
j'ai le quart esprits dans la commission
des finances est un petit peu plus tard
dans la semaine didier migaud président
de la cour des comptes qui tient à peu
près la même analyse qu'est la même
analyse plus ou moins que gilles carez
on peut laisser comme ça filer les
déficits
on est sur la stratégie de la grèce de
l'espagne
ils ont raison de dire il ya un déficit
qui s'accroît mais ils n'ont pas la
solution ils veulent encore plus de
déficit en fait ils veulent encore
appuyé sur le frein un peu plus ce
qu'ils n'ont pas compris tout cet
aéropage bien sûr rezé lé déficit c'est
ça le problème c'est que quand vous êtes
dans la récession
quand vous vous occupez pas de la
création de richesse d'entreprises
quand vous avez une monnaie trop forte
et que vous réduisez d'un coup les
dépenses brutalement sacré plus de
déficits parce que vous alimenter la
machine infernale de la récession c'est
ce que fait l'europe
moi je propose une autre politique
raisonnable c'est celle que fait le
premier ministre japonais
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a dit ça fait
dix ans que le japon est dans la crise
on va de déficit en déficit la dette
augmente et pourtant on réduit les
dépenses c'est curieux alors il a dit
moi je vais faire ce que font les états
unis la chine
je vais baisser la valeur de ma monnaie
de 20% pour que les entreprises
exportent puisse créer la richesse sur
le dans le pays et quand on crée la
richesse dans un pays c'est curieux vous
le savez eh bien il ya des recettes
fiscales plus oui mais c'est pourquoi
moi je suis cohérent
moi je vous dis que tant qu'on gardera
cette monnaie qui nous tue on aura
toujours plus de chômage toujours moins
de recettes fiscales toujours plus de
déficit alors vous allez réduire des
dépenses très bien et puis vous aurez
encore plus déficit à la suisse ans de
fonctionnement c'est bien sûr
mais faisons ce qu'a fait la grèce
continuant il échoue lamentablement et
ils ne veulent pas comprendre les causes
de leur échec moi je m'intéresse à la
création de richesses en france
baisser les charges des pme eux baisser
la valeur de la monnaie pour exporter
simplifier l'administration avoir une
vraie politique pour nos pme et noémie
et pour relocaliser l'emploi c'est la
seule solution questions très concrètes
députés versent émulateur également 10
fiscalité écologiste pourquoi ne pas
augmenter le taxe sur le diesel 2
centimes par exemple est d'accord avec
ça mais vous croyez pas qu'il ya ces
taxes on va mourir sous les taxes on a
le record du monde de taxes donc on veut
toujours plus équilibrer le budget et ce
faisant ont fait fuir nos entreprises
les etats-unis ont créé ont perdu trois
millions de chômeurs ils ont créer 3
millions d'emplois depuis 2009 la zone
euro a créé trois millions de chômeurs
depuis 2009
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les états unis ils
n'ont pas dit on réduit les dépenses
tout de suite ils ont dit on relance
économique ont fait baisser le dollar
ils ont nationalisé l'automobile ils ont
pris des mesures protectionnistes
qu'est ce que fait le japon la même
chose alors est-ce qu'on ne peut pas
changer de politique prendre les
politiques qui marche
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
dans le monde savait la zone euro c'est
la seule zone avec le zimbabwe et
l'afghanistan où il ya la récession la
transparence nicolas du point il sait
qu'à l'assemblée il ya eu ce vote cette
semaine deux votes la transparence de la
vie publique création d'une haute
autorité les déclarations de patrimoine
des élus consultable à la demande mais
sans publicité
les déclarations d'intérêts également
seront publiées sur internet les
activités professionnelles des
intéressés mais aussi des conjoints ça
c'est aussi important
nicolas dupont aignan c'est voter est-ce
que tout va changer
je pense que c'est un + moi je me suis
abstenu parce que je pense qu'on aurait
pu faire beaucoup mieux mais il ya
beaucoup de frilosité de peur je pense
notamment qu'on devrait interdire
l'activité d'avocat de conseil qui est
extrêmement dangereuse et
inconstitutionnelle soi-disant sol et
c'est toujours à constitutionnel quand
on veut pas agir en france donc on
connaît la musique
ça veut dire quoi qu'il ya eu des
loossois d'une importante caution il ya
des lobbys dépression moi ce qui me
révolte c'est qu'on va interdire un
député d'être maire de sa ville où il
est proche de ses habitants où il fait
quelque chose sur le terrain et on va
autoriser des députés dans des cabinets
d'affaires et ben bravo
en attendant c'est quand même un plus
tout ce qui sera fait pour qu'il y ait
la transparence de la moralisation sera
positif si des hommes et des femmes de
leur capacité à être honnête le
président d'une association a publié
vendredi les détails de l'utilisation de
cette fameuse un réserve parlementaire
c'est-à-dire cet argent alloués aux
députés pour qu'ils leur distribuer dans
sa circonscription
peut-on elle peut atteindre plusieurs
millions d'euros on l'a vue là il a
publié une liste
est-ce qu'il faut la rendre totalement
publiques et transparentes qu'on sache
qu existent exactement où va cet argent
mais la réserve à long terme bien sûr
qu'il faut leur en transparence
d'ailleurs il ya une bonne chose depuis
monsieur bartolone
à treize mois j'ai pu et je vais donner
toujours moi j'avais jamais de réserve
parlementaire avant c'est pourquoi parce
que j'étais pas cire pompes et un lèche
bottes on vous donnera je n'ai rien
puisque j'étais non inscrits je
n'appartiens pas à l'ump au ps
donc maintenant de rassure monsieur
bartolone maintenant on a une réserve
est gage projet cent cinquante mille
euros que j'ai écrit à mme et mr de ma
vie de ma circonscription je leur dis
vous qu'est ce que vous en faites
eh ben je finance et projet de
subvention c'est tout ils voulaient
rendre publique la mairie a rien de
secret on a financé le cazin l'abrité
caillebotte à hier j'ai proposé à la
ville de brunoy à côté m'a proposé un
projet d'aménagement public mais ce
qu'il faudrait pas supprimer cette
réserve parlementaire tout simplement
pour les jeux tu trouves pas non non il
veut pas on vous pose simplement la
question pourquoi pas oui c'est la fin
david survivance un peu d'ancien régime
on pourrait faire des économies qu'on la
donne pour les pme pour baisser les
charges des petites entreprises
ça fait quand même partie des mesures
qui n'ont pas été prises
bien sûr mais si vous voulez une espèce
toujours de combat d'arrière garde en
même temps je me méfie de ce jeu lave
plus blanc qui sont de la pub toujours
en demandant plus moi je crois que les
français attendent de notre part la rig
l'honnêteté la transparence voilà allez
voir partir au sénat si vous voulez bien
avec cette commission d' enquête sur le
dopage dans le sport français
elle remettra ses conclusions le 18
juillet prochain mais elle a frappé un
grand coup cette commission cette
semaine c'est une information qui a été
sorti par le journal l'équipe l'ancien
camp cycliste laurent jalabert aurait
été testé positif à l epo en 98 un coup
de tonnerre au moment où le tour de
france va partir pour son centenaire
regardez le reportage de fleurs sauvages
c'était le 15 mai dernier laurent
jalabert était auditionnée par la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur
l'efficacité de la lutte contre le
dopage et déjà face aux sénateurs
l'ancien coureur cycliste laissé planer
un doute sur son usage de l'eau pe lors
du tour de france de 1998
nous étions soigner de quelle manière
aujourd'hui est ce que je peux dire que
c'était de façon illégale
je n'en ai pas la certitude pas de plus
que j'ai la certitude que c'était de
façon légale
aujourd'hui la commission d' enquête a
révélé que laurent jalabert aurait eu
recours à le pe lors du tour de france
de 1998
les sénateurs se sont appuyés sur des
échantillons prélevés en 98 et analysés
en 2004 car dans les années 90 la
détection de le pays n'est pas encore
possible
il y avait effectivement dès lors qu'on
n'était pas à même de détecter le p o
une tentation très forte pour les
sportifs d'y avoir recours
mais fort heureusement les modes de
détection du dopage ont progressé et il
n'est pas il ne serait pas anormal de
procéder à des analyses rétrospectives
mais limité à des périodes de temps
raisonnable dans le passé ainsi les
sénateurs ont pu mettre au jour une
liste de noms de coureurs cyclistes qui
se serait dopé
une liste qui devrait être rendue
publique lors de la parution du rapport
sénatorial le 18 juillet et sera
possible
de prendre connaissance d'une liste de
coureurs qui à l'évidence on utilisait
de le paix au cours de ce tour 1998
laurent jalabert a renoncé ce matin à
ses activités de consultant pour france
télévisions
alors que le départ du centième tour de
france sera donné samedi
ces spécialistes étaient satisfaites
voulez je vous dis ce que je tombe à oui
c'est n'importe quoi pourquoi ce
sénateur il ya autre chose à faire
savoir qu'en 98 de monsieur machin
appris ceci moi j'aimerais qu'on
s'occupe de l'avenir c'est curieux que
la sent que les chaînes enquête mais non
mais attendez
arrêtons cette espèce de de retour vers
le passé de justicier occupons-nous la
délinquance dans nos banlieues où la
justice va sortir tous les malfrats les
deux trafiquants de drogue mais 6 mai
occupons nous des problèmes des français
d'aujourd'hui
luttons contre le dopage dans le tour
qui commence mais arrêtons cette espèce
de retour vers le passé de pseudo
justicier alors qu'ils sont pas foutu de
faire travailler le pays et de faire
avancer les choses aujourd'hui table est
rase il aurait fallu faire l'impasse ne
pas faire ça la plage locale qui est une
commission denquête bien sûr mais
arrêtons de revenir 15 ans avant
m'écouter on peut faire toutes les
poubelles de l'histoire
ça va servir à quoi en revanche moi ce
qui m'intéresse dans cette commission
denquête c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour qu'aujourd'hui on ait un beau
tour de france qui est un grand
événement populaire et yves celui ci les
français sont si déprimée c'est parce
qu'on leur fasse toujours les problèmes
du passé et qu'on traite pas ceux
d'aujourd'hui et demain
donc moi j'aimerais qu'on parle d'eux
hier aussi c'est pas des oeillères c'est
de s'occuper de l'avenir que le sénat
s'occupe d'empêcher le dopage
aujourd'hui voilà que le sénat s'occupe
mais revenir à 98,1 je vais vous montrer
une liste de joueurs compris de jupons
quoi en 98 c'est n'importe quoi a
pardonné mois de froid y agir violemment
c'est votre avis on va passer le
mercredi jérôme cahuzac et devant les
députés
c'est donc l'audition événement jérôme
cahuzac en personne est entendu par les
30 députés de la commission denquête
deux heures d'audition et bien peu de
réponses et lisa berthelot et ne rien
dire ne rien lâcher qui pourrait porter
préjudice
si l'on devait résumer l'audition de
jérôme cahuzac par la commission
denquête ce serait ça etc encore la
question que vous me posez
je suis au regret de vous dire qu'elle
me semble inquiéter non pas aux
frontières mais pleinement sur
l'information judiciaire en cours et je
ne peux pas vous répondre
j'espère qu'à votre tour vous
comprendrez que je ne peux pas répondre
à votre question je suis contraint de
faire la même réponse monsieur le
président je ne peux pas me répondre
donc je prends acte que vous ne répondez
pas à ces deux questions
deux heures d'audition dans une ambiance
pesante deux heures pendant lesquelles
jérôme cahuzac a esquivé les questions
des députés
tout juste est il revenu sur son
mensonges proférés dans l'hémicycle le 5
décembre 2012
je vous ai menti en vous répondant
monsieur le député tout simplement parce
que dans les heures qui précédaient
j'avais menti au premier ministre et au
président de la république pas de
précisions sur son compte à l'étranger
ni d'exposition de ses sentiments
pas de charge contre le chef de l'état
ou ses anciens collègues du gouvernement
impassible jérôme cahuzac reconnaît
avoir traversé cette affaire seuls je ne
dis je les dis la vérité à personne et
en particulier pas à mon avocat qui
était aussi un ami et qui a donc été en
droit sont formalisées de manière assez
vigoureuse à mon encontre et que ce que
je dois désormais assumée avec le reste
je n'ai pas dit la vérité à mes amis je
n'ai pas dit la vérité à mes collègues
je n'ai pas dit la vérité à mes
collaborateurs
c'est ainsi en début d'audition il avait
juré de dire la vérité face à la
trentaine de députés venus l'écouter
jérôme cahuzac a préféré le silence pour
réserver ses réponses aux juges en
charge de l'enquêté judiciaire
quand jérôme cahuzac répond qu il
réserve ses réponses au juge
d'instruction il a raison de le faire
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ces images
sont terribles pour pour lui pour tout
le monde
voilà maintenant moi je crois que et
c'est l'objet du l'avenir justement
c'est d'éviter que tout ça se reproduise
un jour parce que les dégâts sont
considérables
quand même commission denquête pendant
pendant une information judiciaire ça
veut dire aussi que cette commission
s'était peut-être pas le bon moment je
ne sais pas je ne suis pas assez de
férus endroit pour voir comment jérôme
cahuzac instrumentaliser ou pas cette
procédure judiciaire donc ce que je dis
simplement c'est que moi ce qui
m'importe maintenant c'est qu'on ne
revoit plus jamais ça comme quoi ce
machin telle qu'elle a été votée mais
vous savez vous pouvez voter toutes les
lois du monde il ya l'honnêteté la
malhonnêteté l'afrique d'aujourd'hui
non c'est parce que je dis j'ai pas dit
ça
nous devons mettre en place tous les
systèmes législatifs pour obliger les
gens à être contrôlée mais au fond des
choses il ya quand même la conscience
humaine voilà et d'ailleurs vous le
voyez avec ces images terribles
il est confronté maintenant il est face
à lui même voilà donc maintenant je
crois face aux juges oui face à lui même
aussi mais aussi par exemple que les
soupçons qui ont pesé par exemple son
gouvernement sur le ministre des
finances sur le premier ministre l'avait
est-ce qu'il ya plus de soupçons
possible mais pas ce que je sais en
revanche c'est que la france en a pas
fini avec le secret et avec ce type de
pratiques
est ce que j'aimerais ça sera le sens de
mon rapport parlementaire avec alain
bocquet que nous publierons mois
d'octobre sur les paradis fiscaux
ce que j'aimerais c'est que l'état au
delà du folklore que l'état se donne les
moyens d'enquêté que l'état achète les
listes que l'allemagne achète les états
unis hachette voilà qu'on se donne les
moyens savoir la vérité est là je peux
vous dire des cahuzac il y en avoir
quelques uns l'évasion fiscale justement
a été question avec l'audition de
dominique strauss kahn qui nous envient
auditionné mais n'y voyez aucun lien ni
que non mais enfin ça donne pas une
image quand même du parlement
extraordinaire on va regarder le sujet
suscite bien des têtes auditionné devant
cette commission d' enquête sur
le rôle des banques dans les paradis
fiscaux reportage réaction avec et
jérôme rabier c'est par une porte
dérobée donnant sur le parking
souterrain du palais du luxembourg que
dominique strauss kahn est entré dans la
salle de son audition plutôt détendu il
prend le temps de saluer les sénateurs
présents et se prêtent même quelques
instants au jeu des photos
à 15 heures les journalistes sont priés
de monter en tribune de presse et
l'audition peut enfin commencer
monsieur dominique strauss kahn prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité
veillez levé la main droite et dire je
le jure je jure interrogé en tant
qu'ancien directeur général du fmi
il ne se prive pas d'adresser une pique
à françois hollande pour qui la finance
et l ennemi lors de la campagne
présidentielle
de mon point de vue incriminé la finance
dans le désastre économique que nous
vivons en europe en général et en
particulier dans notre pays a pour moi à
peu près la même pertinence que
incriminé l'industrie automobile quand
on parle des morts sur la route
sur un ton très professoral dominique
strauss kahn a délivré pendant 1h20 une
leçon d'économie développant sa vision
de la finance et du contrôle nécessaires
à son bon fonctionnement
désormais le gendarme n'est pas assez
armé laisser aller je dirais volontiers
des superviseurs sont nuls
enfin ça nous a rapprochés je peux pas
dire ça comme ça si on veut surveiller
correctement ce qui se passe à
financière il faut que les surveillants
là c'est plus tellement l'équipement ce
pas la machine qu'il faut c'est bon
homme et la compétence pour le faire
pour la sortie c'est cette fois par la
grande porte qu'il choisit de quitter le
palais son apparition publique ne
pouvons se limiter à une arrivée et un
départ en catimini
il est pour cela servi puisque une nuée
de caméras qui était la moindre
déclaration
si la commission d' enquête sur le rôle
des banques dans l'évasion fiscale
voulait s'offrir un peu de publicité
l'objectif est atteint aucune caméra
n'est cependant rester pour la suite des
auditions de la journée preuve que la
personnalité de l'ex directeur du fmi
importer plus que le sujet sur lequel
ils étaient interrogés choqué par le
fait qu'il soit auditionné ou pas à
titre personnel oui oui parce que je
pense que la vie politique de notre pays
n'a pas besoin de ça et je trouve que
pour le goût du sensationnel la
commission denquête a porté un coup une
nouvelle fois l'image de la politique
dans notre pays
d'accord mais c'est quand même une
personnalité j'ai lue et reconnue pour
son expertise économique connue et
reconnue pour beaucoup d'autres choses
aussi et j'estime que la france à ce
problème fondamental qu'elle ne discerne
plus le bien du mal et moi je fais la
politique parce que je crois qu'il ya
d'apporter le bien et à combattre le mal
on va parler si je profite de la madame
une affaire grave et que cette classe
politique cette classe médiatique cette
classe financière et pas tous attention
beaucoup différents que si elle continue
à jamais différencier les comportements
des gens et en sorte de donner un
rattrapage à ce monsieur qui a sali la
politique française est sali la france
et bien moi ça ne m'intéresse pas et
donc je n'aurais pas fait ça n'aurait
pas dû l'inviter
non il a sali la france on va parler du
fond peut-être être chargée à
l'assemblée d'une mission sur les
paradis fiscaux
quand dominique strauss kahn dit que ce
que l'on a fait jusqu'à présent
finalement ne sert pas à grand chose il
parle pas de la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui sont pas
très utiles
les solutions c'est quoi vous avez
auditionné vous dans le cadre de la
mission d'information
beaucoup de monde que ressort-il de
cette mission d'information vous avez
bientôt rendre leurs rapports et quelles
sont les solutions à votre avis mais
écoutez moi d'abord ce que j'ai
découvert avec effroi c'est qu'au delà
des grands discours c'est vrai que pas
grand chose n'avait été vraiment fait
premier point deuxième point
contrairement à ce qu'on croit on
pourrait prendre beaucoup de mesures
concrètes qui permettraient à l'état et
donc
france de récupérer beaucoup d'argent et
on pourrait baisser les impôts ou
réduire les déficits comme ray comment
on va le proposer dans notre rapport par
justement armée l'état armée l'état
c'est à dire que vous savez dans depuis
20 ans on ne croit plus à l'état si ce
n'est l'état pour donner de l'assistanat
l'état obèses mais l'état c'est un état
régalien
c'est par exemple que quand on fait de
la fraude fiscale aux états unis on peut
faire 15 ans de prison
quand on fait de la fraude fiscale en
france il croit un condamné en prison
pour fraude fiscale aujourd'hui dans
notre pays
oui voilà le message allez voter gelé
voter mais on est encore très loin j'ai
fait voter un amendement avec le soutien
contre le gouvernement avec le soutien
du ps et des communistes d'ailleurs pour
par exemple renverser la charge de la
preuve sur le blanchiment c'est à dire
quand on va découvrir dans le coffre
d'une voiture 1 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui c'est aux douanes de trouver
la cause
on sait bien désormais comme dans tous
les pays démocratiques
ce sera la personne qu'elle est petite
coupure de prouver d'où ça vient bref il
ya quantité de mesures techniques qui
seront dans notre rapport qui
permettront d'armé bercy de donner à
l'état les moyens de se faire respecter
que tu es lutter seul contre l'évasion
fiscale il s'agit là du thé sol mais
aujourd'hui d'accord non c'est un
problème mondial
d'abord pour commencer non non non c'est
un problème d'abord nationales d'avoir
les outils
ce conte l'allemagne la belgique
l'espagne l'italie etats-unis et pas
nous donc il faut se les donner
ensuite c'est une loi sur onze ans sur
la fraude fiscale
oui mais c'est insuffisant on peut faire
beaucoup mieux c'est déjà bien mais
c'est insuffisant
et puis il y aura nos mesures et puis
ensuite il ya une coordination mondiale
et c'est le rapport de force
mais vous savez les français rêvent
surtout le petit milieu politique rêve
de croire qu'au niveau européen j'en
suis d'accord à 27 jamais si on avance
mais change l'échangé des données mais
quand on va dans le bon sens dans le bon
sens et vous savez comment c'est arrivé
c'est pas la france n'est pas l'europe
sont les états unis qu'on dit maintenant
on discute plus
c'est pas des pays voulait pas toujours
oui mais nous aussi on a des moyens de
pression anciens plus important que la
une aussi vous savez vous savez si la
france et l'allemagne décidé ensemble
qu'on interdit la présence dans nos pays
de banques suisses qui ont effet des
compos qui ont des comportements
illégaux comme aux états unis il ya
longtemps que ce serait fini
si on achetait les listes mais est ce
qu'on veut vraiment publier le nom des
personnalités de notre pays des vip
français qui ont des comptes en suisse
c'est ça le problème de fond donc vous
savez si on veut lutter contre la fraude
fiscale
on peut on aura n'arrivera pas tout mais
il faut donner un grand coup de pied
dans la fourmilière et j'ai pas le
sentiment que le milieu politique
français et soit prêt dans la loi sur la
fraude fiscale votée cette semaine on
pourra désormais recourir dans une
enquête à tout type de preuves y compris
légales c'est une bonne chose je les
demande et de nombreux soit les trois
listes sauf qu'on va pas assez loin
encore on pourrait faire mieux notamment
acheter directement les listes que fait
madame merkel avec beaucoup de succès ce
que font ce que fait monsieur obama il a
payé 100 4 millions de dollars les
informateurs 104 millions de dollars et
nous on dira on et nice 2 3 millions la
regarde pas
vous voyez il ya encore de la marge mais
vous verrez vous aurez des
renseignements dans mon rapport dans
notre rapport avec alain bocquet qui
vont surprendre beaucoup
allez on va passer va faire du bien
viendrez nous en reparler très
certainement on va passer au jeudi
les chinois sont à paris ils ont passé
la semaine à visiter les palais de la
république lundi avec françois hollande
dès jeudi au sénat de grands patrons
accueilli par le monsieur chine jean
pierre raffarin en ces temps de crise il
fallait les cajoler marie brémaud il les
reçoit avec tous les égards et n'hésite
pas à donner de sa personne
c'est fini aujourd'hui pour cette
délégation chinoise
le maître de maison c'est jean pierre
raffarin il amusé cajole prend la pose
un exotisme un français qui visiblement
c'est l'affectif société mais derrière
cette visite au pas de charge il ya une
affaire de gros sous au sénat le cac40
chinois les grandes entreprises qui
veulent investir en fils on a besoin des
investissements étrangers pour soutenir
la croissance en europe et donc en
europe il ya des projets il faut faire
en sorte que la france puisse se
valoriser ces projets auprès des
investisseurs chinois montent et les
mérites de l'industrie française mettre
en avant les atouts et les bénéfices de
potentiel partenariat de part et d'autre
on discute on négocie c'est son marché
il y à de nombreuses opportunités à nos
sauveurs businesses la france est à la
pointe dans l'économie numérique dans la
santé dans l'agriculture et dans
l'aérospatiale c'est une longue liste de
ces grands patrons sont tous membres du
club des entrepreneurs de chine qui
génère environ 20 % de la richesse
peuple dans le pays des investisseurs
potentiels qu'il ne faut pas craindre et
ne pas laisser filer
nous avons coopéré avec les américains
dans le passé ça continue d'ailleurs
et donc il faut obligatoirement coopérer
avec les chinois parce que si nous ne le
faisons pas nous d'autres le feront à
notre place pour l'heure seuls 4 % les
investissements étrangers en france sont
chinois mais avec l'opération séduction
de jean-pierre raffarin
d'autres changent vous avez entendu il
faut coopérer avec les chinois vous êtes
d'accord ou pas qu'on ait des échanges
avec la chine c'est fondamental le
général de gaulle avait reconnu la chine
avant tout le monde
nous avons une position à tenir et c'est
très important
mais là c'est pas ça va c'est quoi alors
glace et on vend le pays
un nation qui trichent avec toutes les
règles du jeu c'est comme si vous jouiez
oui c'est comme si vous jouiez au poker
ou au bridge ou à la belote avec
quelqu'un qui triche qui amasse tout
l'argent de ces tricheries et qui après
vient vous racheter votre maison c'est
ça qui se passe c'est la chine
sous-évaluer sa monnaie de 50% la chine
eux est le leader de la contrefaçon et
ne respectent aucune des règles omc la
chine pique les brevets de nos
entreprises et l'europe principalement
est à plat ventre et jouent chacun son
petit jeu madame merkel fayote avec la
chine
monsieur raffarin fait les vrp et
pendant ce temps là il continue à
tricher avec toutes les règles du jeu
donc moi je vous dis une chose très
simple
les chinois ne connaissent comme les
américains d'ailleurs que le rapport de
force il ya un déficit colossal avec la
chine de l'europe dont on est en
position de force puisqu'il nous vendent
bien plus ils nous achètent et nous
vendent bien plus que nous leur achètent
des chiens de faiblesse que toute force
madame puisque si on met des barrières
c'est eux qui perdent c'est pas nous
nous de toute façon on perd donc on est
en position de force
est ce que je vous dis c'est qu'il faut
faire avec les chinois ce qu'ont fait
les américains c'est à dire que quand
les américains mettent des droits de
douane sur les pneumatiques à 90% pour
sauver l'industrie automobile
diplomatique
aux etats unis les chinois s'incline
parce qu'ils ne connaissent que le
rapport de force mais avec l'europe
c'est très simple ils ruinent notre
industrie et avec l'argent qu'ils ont
gagné sur notre dos ils viennent nous
racheter
si on continue comme ça on sera un
peuple d'esclaves et moi je n'aime pas
les collabos voilà et je veux défendre
l'intérêt de mon pays mais ces critères
dans une crise est pas bon quand même de
fermer sa mère avec les chinois mais
même si on connaît les règles du jeu que
vous avez mis sur la table non parce que
vous savez vous posez la question
beaucoup d'entreprises joyent est un
chef d'entreprise par exemple quand les
entreprises françaises signent des
contrats avec la chine
il ya une clause d'arbitrage par exemple
justice privée vous connaissez qu'à
faire tapis d'arbitrage et il me disait
c'est très curieux tous les arbitrages
ont perdu avec la chine puisque il
triche dans l'arbitrage bon ça veut dire
qu'il ya un moment il faut dire aux
chinois vous êtes nos amis il ya une
grande civilisation chinoise on est prêt
à vous aider on est prêt à coopérer
mais il ya une règle du jeu et nous il
faut nous respecter aussi
et les chinois il aime les gens forts
pas les faibles on n'est pas faible
on est couché et c'est pas comme ça
qu'on défendra l'europe alors en
revanche qu on est d accord de
coopération technologique et c'est qu'on
avance oui avec toutes les régions du
monde mais arrêtons cette vente par
appartements de notre pays
c'est tragique on aura compris que les
dirigeants chinois ne sont pas passés
par votre bureau cette semaine mais
attendez j'ai des relations et des
chinois et le discours ils peuvent le
comprendre il voudrait une france forte
pas une france d'esclaves
c'est ça la différence pour le futur
merci à nicolas dupont aignan d'abord
être avec nous dans cette émission l on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine semaine
prochaine à tout ce week-end au revoir